CBS News has learned the Trump
administration may soon discourage
Americans from taking cruises due to the
number of outbreaks aboard some ships
the administration is also working to
meet the surging demand for test kits as
fears and concerns of possible symptoms
appear to be spreading faster than the
virus itself we judge Aang is traveling
with the president who's spending the
weekend at his mar-a-lago resort in
Florida Ouisa good morning good morning
Michelle and good morning to everybody
vice president Mike Pence is also
planning to be here in Florida today to
meet with Cruise Line executives to talk
about what additional measures companies
can take to keep people safe he is still
leading the fight against coronavirus
but there are times when he and
President Trump delivered different
messages adding to any confusion made
great progress but there is much work to
be done on Friday vice president Mike
Pence said the high demand for
coronavirus tests would be met soon we
trust in a matter of weeks the chroma
virus test will be broadly available to
the public and available in any American
that is symptomatic and has a concern
just hours earlier President Trump
offered a much more immediate timeline
anybody right now
anybody that needs a - gets a test and
the test you'll perfect what the letter
is perfect
the transcription President Trump
appeared to be referring to his phone
call with the Ukrainian president at the
center of his impeachment even as he
toured the Centers for Disease Control
and tried to tamp down concerns about
the growing outbreak I said calm have to
be come before leaving Washington for
the weekend mr. Trump signed an eight
point three billion dollar response
funding bill to research the disease and
stop it from spreading dr. Anthony Fauci
offered a solution for those who may be
at risk especially the elderly think
twice even before you get on a plane for
a long trip or you want to travel or you
want to go to a place that's crowded
where there may be people speaking of
crowds President Trump said he has no
plans to halt campaign rallies tens of
thousands of people standing outside the
arena so
doesn't bother me at all and it doesn't
bother them despite that confidence
after several packed weeks of rallies
right now there are none scheduled on
the campaign's official schedule here in
Florida today the president only has one
item on his agenda that's hosting the
Brazilian President for dinner at
mar-a-lago Jeff we just thank you very
much